in 1964 a young psychologist appeared
before the u.s congress with a mission
it was a time when most people thought
that the reason poor people stayed poor
was a matter of biology and had nothing
to do with the environment they grew up
in the psychologist yuri bronfenbrenner
wanted to change that and convinced the
world that to help those less fortunate
we also needed to change their
surroundings but did he succeed
[Music]
braun finn brenner's ecological system
theory conceives that a child is
influenced by five ecological forces
first comes the microsystem of family
and friends that affect the child
directly second are the forces of the
connections between the people around
the child parents with teachers and
teachers with peers then there are links
between social settings that do not
directly involve the child such as the
father with his boss the peers with
their parents and the teacher with the
principal next is the overarching
culture religion and social norms that
influences all others and lastly there
is time which changes everything over
the course of one's life
[Music]
children are born into a microsystem
that influences the child's experiences
directly children from unfortunate
backgrounds are more likely to
experience problematic family structures
even if it's simply for the fact that
parenting is more difficult if you are
poor they also encounter more negative
situations at school or bad influences
through friends consequently a child
that grows up in a negative microsystem
will find it hard to succeed
[Music]
the mesosystem represents the
interconnections between the elements
that surround the child
for example the relationship between the
father and the schoolteachers if the
father doesn't get along with a teacher
the child might suffer
[Music]
the exo system involves the links
between social settings that do not
involve the child for example a child's
experience at home can be influenced by
their parents experiences at work if the
mother loses her job there might be more
arguments with the father resulting in
changes in their interaction with the
child
the macro system describes the
overarching culture that influences all
other systems such as a child's
geographic location and ethnicity
intelligent people who happen to live in
bad places are more likely to move to
better ones but that also means that
they are more likely to be strangers in
a richer society so regardless of the
child's biological potential or
upbringing on a macro level he or she
may still be at a disadvantage
[Music]
the chrono system refers to changes in
the child and the environment over time
as the child grows up the parents may
stop loving each other and divorce which
can be traumatic for an eight-year-old
boy five years later he may have come to
terms with how things turned out but
when the boy turns 16 his mom's new
boyfriend moves into their tiny
apartment and things get difficult again
[Music]
broffen brenner who was influenced by
lev bygotsky and kurt lewin convinced
the us congress that a child's prospect
is not genetically predestined but is
the result of the larger environment
they happen to be placed in
children who grow up in unfortunate
social structures therefore need a form
of support that not only reaches their
families but also elements of their
community bronfenbrenner's theory helped
form the head start program in 1965 a
government program that has served more
than 35 million poor children since
decades later bronfenbrenner and steven
cessy proposed an extension of this
theory called the bioecological model
this new model recognizes gene
environment interactions and
acknowledges the role of heritability
but adds that genes themselves are under
the influence of the environment in
other words the process of heritability
varies in a magnitude of potentials how
much a child can make of the potential
they inherit
depends on the ecological environment
[Music]
bronfenbrenner made a critical
contribution to our realization that
parent-child relationships do not exist
in a social vacuum but are embedded in
the larger structures such as community
society and culture
in order to develop well he allegedly
said every child needs at least one
adult who is irrationally crazy about
him or her
[Music]
now it's your turn make five circles
draw yourself in the center and add a
timeline at the bottom
then put all the people institutions and
forces that affect you through the five
different systems
on the timeline below you can add some
major events from the past and those you
expect in the future can you tell how
the five forces are shaping your life to
read more about the topic or download
the video without background music visit
sproutschools.com
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts